rhaenyra is one of the main characters
in the targaryen civil war at the heart
of the show emma darcy is casted to play
her the cast nicole described her as
king viserys's chosen heir a dragon
rider who grew up expecting to become
the first ruling queen of westeros
the official description describes her
as the king's first born child she is of
pure valyrian blood and she is the
dragon rider
many would say that rhaenyra was born
with everything but she was not born a
man princess rhaenyra targaryen cheered
as the realm's delight when she was
young and later called the half-year
queen was the first born child of king
viserys the first targaryen reiner was
king viserys is the first only living
child by his first wife queen emma of
house serene
at the age of 8 she was made her
father's heir and grew up expecting to
become the first ruling queen of
westeros
rhaenyra was a dragon rider whose mount
was cyrex rhaenyra had her family's
valyrian looks varying her silver gold
hair in a long braid in the manner of
queen mazania targaryen
beautiful as a child rhaenyra was later
declared by her uncle prince daemon
targaryen to be the most beautiful
maiden in all the seven kingdoms
due to the lack of a male heir viserys
designated rhaenyra as his successor
therefore rhaenyra was the only female
targaryen to lay claim to the iron
throne in her own right
since she was raised as the designated
heir rhaenyra became quite pampered and
arrogant but also gained practical
governmental experience after rhaenyra's
mother died her father remarried and had
several sons with his second wife
alicent of house hightower even so
viserys still publicly expected his
daughter to succeed him and when he died
his official will even stated so however
rhaenyra's younger half-brother aegon
challenged her claim
he stated that the normal inheritance
loss of the andals which form the basis
of the unified law code in westeros
called for male preference primogeniture
meaning that a younger son would
rightfully inherit before an older
daughter at the time of her father's
death rhaenyra was done dragonstone
evading the birth of her child the green
sinking's landing ensured that the news
of izeers's death did not reach her
until her own supporters in the red keep
were dead or imprisoned and aegon the
second's coronation had already occurred
this began a devastating civil war that
tore apart the seven kingdoms known as
the dance of the dragons as it was the
only war in which both sides had dragon
riders rhaenyra had two husbands and
five sons her first husband was lehner
of house valerian son of the sea snake
and her second husband was her uncle
daemon targaryen the rogue prince and
there we come to the second announced
lead actor matt smith will play daemon
george r martin revealed that daemon is
his favorite targaryen so that tells you
something about the character
hbo describes the character as the
younger brother to king viserys and the
heir to the tron
a peerless warrior and the dragonrider
daemon possesses the true blood of the
dragon but it's said that whenever a
targaryen is born the gods toss a coin
in the air demon targaryen also known as
prince of the city lordly bottom and the
rogue prince had many titles throughout
his life prince sir commander of the
city watch master of coin master of loss
king of the stepstones and the narrow
sea protector of the realm daemon was
the most controversial man of his
lifetime an audacious rogue prince and
adventurer who seemed made of good and
evil in equal measure there was never a
man so loved and so reviled and at the
same time as he was during the dance of
the dragons as the husband of his niece
rhaenyra he supported his wife's claim
and he was considered by many the most
dangerous man in westeros he was
rhaenyra's second husband following sir
leonard valorian and she was his third
wife prince damon was the most
experienced warrior of his time and
wielded the valyrian steel blade dark
sister a dragon rider whose dragon was
characters daemon declared himself the
king of the stepstones and the narrow
sea daemon was a skilled warrior
described in the histories as dashing
daring and dangerous he was also
ambitious impetuous mercurial immoral
reckless and quick to take offense he is
described as being as charming as he was
hot tempered daemon's most epic moment
comes from the most epic dragon battle
the battle above the god's eye between
two most dangerous warriors at that time
daemon and aemond targaryen and their
two dragons which also were the
strongest of all vegar and characters
daemon challenged the aemond waiting for
13 days at harehole until aemond stopped
burning the riverlands to come to face
him when characters attacked vulgar she
ripped upon his stomach and tore one of
his wings but then characters fast and
his jaws surround her throat in death
grip these injuries force them both to
cease flying
and as they tumbled to the water below
daemond dueled eamonn to death as he
never fast and his settle daemon stood
up on charaxes and lapped at aymond
whereupon he drove his dark sister
through eamonn's eye and through his
neck just a second before hitting the
water the battle above the god's eye
ended in the deaths of both riders and
both the dragons daemon was 49 when he
died unlike eamonn's body however demons
was never found singers say that damon
lived to spend the rest of his days in
secret with nettles but most historians
disagree
last but not the least hbo also
announced that olivia cook is also lead
actor casted to play alice in hightower
alice in hightower is described as the
daughter of otto hightower the hand of
the king and the most calmly woman in
the seven kingdoms she was raised in the
red keep close to the king and his
innermost circle she possesses both a
courtly race and a keen political acumen
alice and hightower was a member of
house hightower who became the second
wife to king viserys the first targaryen
and therefore a queen of the targaryen
dynasty she was the daughter of seroto
hightower who had been the hand of the
king to jahiris the first viserys the
first and later his grandson aiken ii
she was the mother of king aegon the
second queen hilina prince eamonn and
prince daron alice and hightower was in
many ways the true leader of aegon ii's
faction during the dance of the dragons
at first young rhaenyra and alison got
along well but the rift grew between
them as soon as allison produced her own
children for viserys the first and
clearly wanting them to succeed to the
throne instead of her
ellie sent bore wizards the first four
children aegon the second aemon the one
eye there on the daring and helina who
became the sister wife of aegon ii over
the years of viserys since the first
reign despite his best efforts a better
rivalry grew between alice sent and
raineyright court as well as between the
rival factions of supporters in 111ac a
great tourney was held at king's landing
on the 5th anniversary of the king's
marriage to queen ellison at the opening
feast alison wore a green gown while
princess rhaenyra dressed in targaryen
red and black
soon afterward their respective
followers started dressing in similar
colors and styles to display their
political allegiance rhaenyra's faction
the princess's followers wore black
clothing in dallas faction the queen's
followers wore green clothing
ultimately this inspired the nicknames
for the two factions the blacks and the
greens viserys the first publicly and
repeatedly made the great lords of the
realms fair oats that rhaenyra would
succeed him on the iron throne as the
first ruling queen
a matter of hours after viserys the
first died in his sleep however ellison
staged a coup
one that she had been long planning to
define details
one night a servant found the old king
had died in his sleep and ran to inform
queen ellison protocol dictated that the
bells would be wrong everyone notified
that the raven sent to dragonstone to
summon the air princess rhaenyra for her
coronation
but ellie sent her daughter planes once
she saw her that husband's body she
sealed the room and had the servant
thrown into the black cells to ensure
his silence
according to mushroom who was away with
rhaenyra targaryen on dragonstone alison
poisoned viserys's drink
true or not instead of announcing
viserys as the first death immediately
alison warned sir christian cole now
lord commander of the kingsguard and
together they called the small council
to discuss the succession where plans
were made to crown ellison's son prince
aegon instead of princess rhaenyra who
had been with serious heir or isn't
viserys drink
true or not instead of announcing
viserys as the first death immediately
alison warned sir christian cole now
lord commander of the kingsguard and
together they called the small council
to discuss the succession where plans
were made to crown alice and son prince
aegon instead of princess rhaenyra who
had been with zerus's heir this started
the targaryen civil war which will be
the key event of the upcoming game of
thrones prequel house of the dragon we
also know the directors for the first
season in addition to game of thrones
sweater and miguel sapochnick who's
serving a showrunner along with ryan
condol the directing team will also
include claire kilner jira patel and
greg yatenis the first season is
confirmed to consist of 10 episodes
house of the dragon is coming thank you
so much for watching if you enjoyed this
video please give it a big thumbs up and
i hope to see you in the next one peace
you